[موسيقى]
من مقبره ابوصير شمال القاهره الى المانيا
ثم الى الولايات المتحده رحله تابوت خشبي
قديم نهب من مصر وعاد الى احضانها فبعد
سنوات من الجهود استعاده القاهره تابوت
الاخضر الذي نهبته شبكه منظمه عام 2016
تهريبه خارج مصر التابوت الاخضر كنز يعود
الى عصور مصر القديمه
هيها ضمن 17 قطعه اثريه اخرى وبعوده هذه
القطاع يؤكد المصريون انهم لن يفرطوا في
حقهم على استعاده تاريخ بلادهم من الخارج
مصر استعاده اكثر من 29 الف قطعه اثريه
لكن يبلغ عدد هذه القطع خارج البلاد في
اقل تقدير طبقا لاحصاءات دقيقه مليون قطعه
يبقى الملف مفتوحا سواء لجهه استعاده
الاثار من المتاحف في الخارج او وقف
عمليات التهريب فخلال عام 2022 وحده تم
ضبط حواليه
3496 قطعه اثريه بالمنافذ المصريه قبل
خروجها من البلاد بطرق غير قانونيه
من اهم القطع الاثريه الفريده خارج مصر هي
حجروا رشيد حاليا في المتحف البريطاني في
لندن ايضا راس نفرتيتي التي تعرض في
المتحف المصري بالعاصمه الالمانيه برلين
[موسيقى]
وزير الملك خوفو ومهندس بناء الهرم الاكبر
يوجد حاليا هذا التمثال في المانيا ايضا
لوحه الزودياك موجوده حاليا في متحف
اللوفر بفرنسا وقطعه من دقن ابو الهول
وتعرض في المتحف البريطاني
يوجد في مصرلات بينما في روما ووحدها
ثماني مسلات مصريه تشير الاحصاءات الى ان
عدد المسلات يصل الى مئه مثلث
[موسيقى]